as data begins to trickle in about the
true case fatality rate for coronavirus
governors begins to talk about reopening
president Trump goes to full-scale war
with the press and burning finally
endorses Biden and by the way so does
Obama I'm Ben Shapiro this is the bench
Bureau show
[Music]
the benton shapiro show is brought to
you by expressvpn do not leave your
internet activity unprotected expressvpn
dot-com / ben go check them out right
now okay so we'll get to it a little bit
later on in the show but apparently
barack obama is going to endorse joe
biden all it took was everyone else to
not be in the race for him to endorse
joe biden's that endorsement means
everything right now barack obama
keeping with that leading from behind
strategy that worked so well for him
during his presidency literally every
single other person in the race had to
be removed and then endorse jacoba for
barack obama to be like hey maybe i
should endorse Trump and that is true
friendship that's true friendship when
you see a friends in need you wait for
every single other human being in the
universe to attempt to help that friend
and then at the very end when they don't
need to help anymore that's when you
sound off I mean just what what a
wonderful relationship those two must
have we'll get to that a little bit
later on in the show first we're gonna
get to everything coronavirus related
but first let's talk about the fact that
everybody is spending an awful lot of
time on the internet right now
traditional security software relies on
a blacklist of known malware but new
malware pops up all the time and
traditional security software cannot
detect it by the time a ransomware
infection is detected it is indeed it
too late have you ever been in a
situation where this has happened it's
really really bad so we will lock the
files on your computer and then
basically force you to pay them in order
to unlock those files on your computer
well in today's world your computer
needs software that can block modern
cyber threats american-made PC Manek
uses a proprietary white list of trusted
programs and applications that are known
to be good of a program isn't on the
white list and they try to execute PC
magic blocks it stopping unknown and
known threats from infecting your
devices if a program hasn't proven to be
trustworthy it doesn't get a key this is
the right way to think about
cybersecurity because other programs
basically let everything in unless you
are saying that I can't get in this one
says you don't get in almost who are
already trusted Android phones tablets
Macs Windows servers Windows computers
from Windows 10 all the way back to XP
and Vista PC Matic will protect all of
those systems PC Matic also makes your
computer run faster by performing
automated maintenance and system
optimization you should be protecting
yourself against now our particularly an
environment where you're on the internet
all the time a single PC Matic
subscription protects five devices for
50 bucks per year if you visit my
special link right now PC Matic calm
slash Ben you get an extra month of
protection
for free pc man it comes with a 30 day
no questions asked money back guarantee
protect your devices but the only virus
developed and supported a hundred
percent in the united states go to pc
Medicom slash Ben to get started right
away
again that is pc manic comm slash Ben go
check them out right now you can't
afford to leave your stuff unprotected
PC manic comm slash Ben go check them
out right this very instant okay so the
continuing question right now is when we
reopen and how we reopen and this has
led to a pretty major conflict between
President Trump and the governor's the
governor suggesting that they have the
authority to reopen president from
claiming he has the authority to reopen
but the big question of course is when
the hell are we supposed to reopen and
how the hell are we supposed to reopen
in the absence of data and I've been
saying this over and over and over we do
not have the data yet we are waiting for
antibodies has to be rolled out now the
problem is that no matter which way you
go there are obstacles right antibody
tests are not perfect let's say that
there are 95 percent effective well that
means the five percent ineffective it
could be getting a 5 percent false
positive rate for people who are quote
unquote
asymptomatic and then you end up with a
perception that the disease is
significantly less deadly than it
actually is because you think a lot of
people have tested positive who actually
never had it and none of them died they
never actually had it but then you're
like oh this thing isn't so deadly right
so that's a possibility
on the other hand if you don't have any
data gathered at all then you are simply
stabbing in the dark at what exactly the
true case fatality rate is for kovat 19
and the one thing we do know is that all
the models that have been used up to now
kind of suck so the University of Sydney
has a has a study out today led by an
international group of data scientists
and their their Center for translational
data science found that over 70 percent
of US states had death rates
inconsistent with the IMA Qi predictions
so remember that famous UW study right
the one that everybody was citing the
White House was siting and saying a
hundred thousand two to two hundred and
forty thousand people could die in the
IMH you study has now been updated again
to say that it'll be closer to 70
thousand dead by the time we hit August
well the Sydney the University of Sydney
Center for translational data science a
um there's the study just sucks
basically they say the study is just
terrible
apparently this this one this group of
statisticians from the University of
Sydney Northwestern University and
University of Texas have collaborated to
fully investigate the predictive
performance of the Cova 19 model
developed by the Institute for Health
metrics and evaluation and what
is the thing stinks all right 70% of US
states had an actual death right outside
the 95 percent prediction interval for
that state casting doubt on whether the
model is suitable to inform kovat 19
resource allocation at all the model
which provides forecasts on a
state-by-state basis across the United
States has been circulated widely by the
media and on social media it was cited
by the White House directly on March
31st University of Sydney statistician
director of the Center for translational
data science professor Sally Crips says
the discrepancy between predicted deaths
and the actual death rate in the United
States has serious implications for the
US government's future planning and
provision of ventilators PPE and the
staffing of medical professionals
equipped to respond to the pandemic they
say the thing is basically useless
professor Martin tanner from
Northwestern University
he says I'm concerned that the UW I am
IH m e motto has had difficulty in
predicting the next day how will the
predictions fare over the long term they
usually say that statisticians give a
range called the prediction interval in
which the actual future values are
likely to lie and that involves
estimating uncertainty a 95 percent
prediction interval is an interval or we
would expect 95 percent of actual future
values to lie so with 95 percent
certainty will lie between one value on
the low end and one value on the high
end and the study is just wrong like a
lot of the time only 30 percent of US
states have actual death counts lying
within the 95 percent prediction
interval 70 percent of the actual death
counts lie outside the 95 percent
prediction interval so in other words
the studies garbage right that's what
the University of Sydney is saying and
that was used as the largest basis for
all of the decision-making going on
about lockdown that's not the only
information that suggests that the
information we've been using has been
highly flawed Scott Gottlieb the former
FDA Commissioner hey he tweeted out a
study those quoted by the New England
Journal of Medicine and he points out
more data on the Cova 19 attack rate in
New York
doctors screened all expectant moms at 1
New York Hospital and they found that
out of 210 mothers 29 were asymptomatic
and positive exposure in New York to
kovat could be very high given emerging
data on the scope of prevalence this
suggests that in hotspots like New York
City the level of kovat 19 exposure and
rates of some immunity one serology
studies are in place could be really
really high not the fifty to sixty six
percent needed to confer herd immunity
but much more than ten percent in hot
spots like part of New York City
according to the actual statistics
what it shows is that of the pregnant
women who came in and they were tested
across the board cuz they're pregnant
they want to make sure the baby did not
get kovat nineteen eighty five percent
were negative eighty four point six
percent were negative thirteen point
five percent were positive in
asymptomatic and one point nine percent
were positive and symptomatic as well
it's a very small sample size but that
does suggest that at least in New York
City
the prevalence is extremely high because
again a lot of these women were really
asymptomatic and if those statistics
were to hold if you were to see
basically for every one symptomatic
person you were to see seven or eight
people who are asymptomatic then the
death rates are way way lower for covin
19 than anybody has suggested previously
because again people keep using case
fatality rate incorrectly people keep
looking at the fact that they're about
two hundred thousand diagnosed people in
New York State and about ten thousand
dead people in New York State and they
say oh well that means ten thousand over
two hundred thousand that means there's
like a five percent death rate if you
get this thing in New York State that's
not true
let's take that stat that was being used
here by the by the hospital okay let's
say that approximately were doing some
rough math some rough mental math here
that for every symptomatic person there
were seven asymptomatic people that
means that not 200,000 people had this
thing in New York State that probably
it's a lot more right probably it's one
point it's one point four million people
had that well one point four million
people ten thousand dying out of one
point four million is a lot less okay
then
now you're talking about now you're
talking about a death rate of point of
0.7 percent ten thousand over one point
four million
okay so if it's point if it's a point
seven percent point seven of eight
percent you're talking about definitely
higher than the that you're talking
about definitely higher than the flu but
it's more in line with head of South
Korea and values because we've seen in
South Korea is point six percent death
rate and that is heavily located among
the elderly and people who have obesity
by the way the number one factor for
coming down with the case of SARS that
lands of Sarrus Kovac nineteen that
lands you in the hospital is obesity
obesity is the the number one factor
according to medical sources at this
point and that would be clinical obesity
meaning about a body mass index above
thirty so if you're overweight that
doesn't necessarily mean you're obese
overweight is
from classification in the body mass
index then obesity is so that New
England Journal of Medicine study tends
to show that there is very very high
prevalence of this thing which also
means it's gonna be extremely difficult
to engage in any testing regimen over
the course of three hundred and thirty
million people that locks everything
down instead what you're gonna have to
do is probably end up with some sort of
tranching scenario not a scenario where
you give immunity certificates again
even the immunity certificates are not
number one they're not a good idea
because you will end up with people
faking immunity certificates just to go
back to work if they're asymptomatic but
beyond that it's it's and not only if
you have privacy concerns beyond all of
that you could have a situation where
you are testing tons and tons and tons
of people and they're coming up negative
because you're testing them in the wrong
area and as we just discussed the
antibody tests our five percent false
positive rate or five percent false
negative rate so the same issue applies
there so the idea that you could give
somebody an immunity certificate and
they're not actually immune they've
never actually had the thing before
that's a fairly significant possibility
and those numbers look enormous when
you're talking about testing 100 million
people which means that in the end as
I've been suggesting we may end up with
something that is just quick and dirty
quick and dirty to get the economy going
and what that is is if you are if you
are elderly if you are in ill health if
you are if you are obese if you're
clinically obese if you have a clinical
heart condition if you are if you are
suffering from an immunological
deficiency if you have any of these
things then you will probably be told to
self quarantine and stay at home until
the vaccine is developed and if you are
young and if you are healthy you will be
told to go back to work you'll be told
that you probably shouldn't congregate
in super large groups but you should be
able to go back to work and you should
socially distance as much as possible
you should wear a mask and that's how we
all go back to work like that is the
most likely scenario at this point
because I think that all of the talk
about contact tracing
again if the prevalence is 14 percent in
the population
ain't no contact tracing happening there
you're just not gonna be able to contact
trace especially because again that does
raise some fairly serious privacy
concerns we discussed yesterday on the
program some of the solutions being put
forward including you download an app
and then you're automatically notified
if somebody who came within a particular
distance of you is is going to it comes
down with Kovan 19 now that is not going
to that's not gonna be good enough
frankly because not everybody's gonna
download the app unless you make it
mandatory in which case you have serious
Fourth Amendment
concerns now I have a little bit more
good news for you in just one second
we'll get to the possibilities here
because again in the in the absence of
certainty and in the knowledge that we
cannot resolve the the uncertainty we're
gonna have to make some decisions okay
right now I've been willing to to kind
of hold off with the with the belief
that the scientists are going to come up
with some more data that's gonna allow
us to make more specific decisions what
if the data and forthcoming at a certain
point we're gonna have to say okay here
is what we think our risk level is based
on percentage of the population based on
who you are based on your youth based on
your your health conditions and then
we're gonna have to say to people you're
gonna have to make best available
decisions about saving your own life by
the way that's called living human life
generally that's called freedom is that
you are going to have to make decisions
about what is riskiest for you if you're
a young person who is you know
compromised you will I think you may I
don't think the government has to
mandate you stay home I think that you
will be staying home I think that you
will understand that this is a risky
situation for you we'll get some more of
this in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that if you are not
protecting your data online you are
making a very large-scale mistake you
need to be protecting your data online
right now the simple fact of the matter
is that as we spend tons and tons and
tons of time online hackers are looking
for all the data that you are expending
online you're using your credit card to
buy stuff from Amazon every single day I
know I am and that means that hackers
this is like a paradise for them you
need to protect your online activity
this is why expressvpn has developed a
technology called trusted server that
makes it impossible for even their
servers to log any of your information
I've tried a lot of VPNs in the past
many of them will slow your connection
down make your device sluggish I've been
using expressvpn though my internet
speeds are continuing to be blazing fast
I can still connect to servers thousands
of miles away still streaming HD quality
videos with zero lag the last thing that
really sets expressive VPN apart it's
really easy to use once you install it
on your computer you are good to go one
click of a button you are now protected
your grandparents could use it Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders could use it and it
is that simple it doesn't make any sense
to leave your data unprotected at this
point in time wherever so protect
yourself with the VPN I use entrust use
my link expressvpn comm slash spend
today get an extra three months for free
on a one-year package that's expr ESS
VPN comm slash Bennigan's express it VPN
comm slash been to learn more go check
them out right now so by the way when I
mentioned the prevalence of the disease
in places like New York City recognized
it's gonna be
extraordinarily high in New York because
of the population density New York is
not like other areas of America and to
pretend that we have to use a
one-size-fits-all policy with regard to
vast swathes of the United States where
population density is 1/100 of what
population density is in New York City
is idiotic you should not be treating a
rural area of Kentucky the same way that
you are treating a big city in New York
by the way you shouldn't be turning LA
like you treat New York ok la has had to
date something like 300 deaths total
yeah like New York has seen literally
thousands of deaths right in New York
City so New York State has seen at this
point a little over 10,000 deaths the
entire state of California which is 40
million people has seen 731 deaths total
the city of Los Angeles has seen
approximately 300 deaths why because the
city of Los Angeles has really spread
out I live in the suburbs you know why
because la is one giant sprawling
suburbs so for all you people in
Hollywood have been ripping on the
suburbs all these years I got some news
for you it turns out the suburbs are
saving your ass
the fact that you're living on top of
each other in small apartments is a very
good thing for you ok but the reality is
that treating all of all of the United
States as though the New York pattern is
going to abide is really foolish it's
really silly and treating the rest of
the world like it's gonna be Wuhan or
like it is going to be northern Italy is
foolish as well you have to control for
differences in population you have to
control for differences in living
patterns you have to control for
intergenerational contact and all the
rest of this stuff and it's very
difficult to control for and you have to
look at how other countries are handling
this sort of stuff because there are
differences and how other countries are
handling this stuff at this time so
pretend that every country is handling
this thing with with equal sort of
capacity is just not true
again I'm going to note but if you take
a look at Sweden right everybody is
ripping on sweet and look how Sweden is
experiencing the spike again you cannot
evaluate whether Sweden did the right
thing and keeping most of their country
open until you have about a year until
about how you have out a year of
experience because right now Sweden has
had about a thousand deaths out of
11,000 diagnosed cases and if you look
at other surrounding countries you know
they're doing slightly better but on a
per million population basis they're not
really doing all that much better right
Switzerland has had about 26
diagnose cases in about eleven hundred
deaths Netherlands has had about twenty
seven thousand diagnosed cases and about
three thousand deaths so another ones is
not doing significantly better than
Sweden is on a percentage basis so the
the notion that Sweden is just getting
blown up because they decided to be a
little bit more open and basically do
what I've been talking about for the
United States the evidence does not
suggest that yet also we have to
determine whether in fact it is the lock
downs that are burning this thing out or
whether there's a natural burnout period
of Iris's because we've really have yet
to see a virus that just continues to
span the globe over and over and over
and over until it wipes out all of human
population or until everybody gets it
well talk in a second about a chairman
of the Israeli Space Agency and National
Council for research and development
he's suggesting there might be a natural
kind of terminus to this thing which
would be the best news of all obviously
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact sleep
quality hard to come by it these days I
will admit that my sleep quality is
disturbed you spend a lot of time
thinking about what's going on in the
world it's hard to fall asleep and then
you have kids who wake up every single
night literally every single night last
night it was my daughter waking us up at
3:30 to inform us and her blanket had
fallen off of her bed which was
obviously an emergency and then it was
our newborn waking us up because she
wanted to eat so if you're having
trouble sleeping you really value the
moments when you are allowed to sleep
and this is why I need my helix sleep
mattress helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper or a hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or from bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN has called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on just head on over to helix
sleep comm /ban take their 2 minutes
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10 year warranty and get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but indeed you will because it is a
mattress that is made for you what's not
to love
helix right now is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash pen that is helix
sleep comm slash Ben go check them out
right now helix sleep comm slash Ben
okay so in other news that could
theoretically be good there is a story
that comes out of Israel from the Israel
national news agency according to
analysis of international graphs and
comparisons Major General Professor
Isaac Ben Israel concludes it is
possible we are already in the final
stage
the corona virus epidemic professor Ben
Israel is the chairman of the Israeli
Space Agency and the National Council
for research and development he's head
of the security studies program at Tel
Aviv University and he explained his
position he points out that when you
measure the rate of additional patients
to existing patients the trends can be
clearly identified and adjusted in all
countries if at the rate of the
beginning of the epidemic the rate of
hospitalization was increasing at a
rapid rate this reality has changed
radically
pretty much every day since and you've
seen this consistently across countries
is a flattening of the curve he says the
incidence of patients was greater by the
day this was during the first four weeks
after the epidemic was discovered in
Israel as of the sixth week the increase
in the number of patients has been
moderate peaking in the sixth week at
700 patients per day since then it's
been declining today they're only 300
new patients in two weeks will reach
zero and there will be no more new
patients he says this is how it is all
over the world in countries where they
took closure steps like Italy and in
countries that didn't have closures like
Taiwan or Singapore in such-and-such
countries there is an increase until the
fourth to sixth week and then
immediately thereafter moderation until
the eighth week it disappears
now that is the most optimistic vision
of course it is possible there's a
second way because we just don't have
the time lag information at this point
with that said that would be an
optimistic vision also it is possible
that there will be a reduction in the
virus and in the viral load that is
carried when we all get outside during
the warm weather see there's this idea
that warm weather kills the virus it's
true warm weather does have an effect on
viruses generally but it is also true
that when you spend a lot of time
outdoors and not indoors that is
actually better for you so let me point
out that the government's policy
particularly in places like California
where it's getting warm already to keep
you inside is almost full-scale idiocy
hey what you really should be is
socially distancing outside sunlight
fresh air
distance from human beings that is what
is going to allow this thing to die out
the fact is that the more time you spend
outside and not in you know a cramped
confined space with other human beings
the less chance you are going to infect
other human beings the wall street
journal has a piece today talking about
this asking whether warmer temperatures
bring a corona virus reprieve many
scientists are predicting a reduced
spread in war months but it's hard to
tell the good news is that the novel
coronavirus comes from a family that
can't take the heat corona viruses in
general are enveloped in a coat of fat
and protein that tends to lose its shape
at high temperatures a process like into
melting that effectively disables the
virus they also tend to survive longest
in
of low humidity if you look at the
confirmed cases per 1 million people it
is much higher in kind of cold countries
than it is in warm countries the corona
virus that causes clove in nineteen
appears to behave like its siblings in
this regard a team of researchers the
University of Hong Kong we studied the
virus in a lab found it was stable in
cool temperatures of around 40 degrees
Fahrenheit it deteriorated over time
when stored at 72 degrees Fahrenheit
which implied the virus would perish
quicker on surfaces like door handles
when it is hot out many scientists
predict reduce spread and warmer
temperatures they cannot say by how much
but as we move towards summer as we move
towards summer we are going to see we
hope some sort of die out from Koba 19
and so the question is going to become
how long can we wait here
that really is the question how long can
we wait is the answer forever because I
don't think that that is survivable I
don't think the American people are
willing to do it I don't think it is
practical and I don't think it's good
for the economy and again to pretend
that you don't care about human life
when you're talking about the
destructions of ten of Milton there are
people who are going to food banks who
never thought in their entire
hard-working human beings who never
thought in their entire life they'd have
to rely on a check from the government
or a can from a food bank literally
never thought this because they wouldn't
have had to in the absence of a massive
government shutdown and now is not the
time to discuss because we don't have
the data whether the shutdown was
completely useful or whether it was a
good idea or not the question now is how
we get out of all of this and as I say I
think that a lot of these sort of more
high-tech solutions know vast testing
millions of tests tests being one out of
employer's we're testing them right now
in the United States something like
130,000 people a day how many people
would you have to test a per day in the
United States to ensure that nobody was
out in public with kovin 19 instead
perhaps we should be looking as the
summer approaches toward keeping our
scientists working hard I'm coming up
with with medication that mitigates the
effects of this thing keeping our
scientists full-scale full-bore going on
vaccine and then letting people who are
healthy go back to work understanding
there's a risk factor that if you get it
that there's a shot that something bad
could happen to you but dividing the
population it is still amazing to me
that when we discuss overall case
fatality rate we're still not being told
every day by the government what the
case fatality rate is for different
types of people
not on a racial ethnic basis which is
what everybody seems to want to know in
the media the racial ethnic basis I care
less a lot less about the racial ethnic
basis because it doesn't identify in
cross-cutting fashion in the strongest
possible correlative fashion with risk
factor right it may be true that it is
riskier to be black and get cove in
nineteen and it is to be waiting at
copán 19 but I will tell you this it is
significantly significantly riskier to
be obese and get Kovan 19 than it is to
be not obese right if you're looking for
correlative factors that allow us to
make decisions about who should go back
to work and who should not go back to
work why don't you pick the strongest
possible correlations not the
cross-cutting weaker correlations it's
just a demonstration of our PC idiocy
that we'll discuss the fact that older
people are more vulnerable to this thing
which is why they should take more
protective measures and we should take
more protective measures around them and
people with immunocompromised systems
should be taking more protective
measures and people who are 30 and in
good health
yes is there a risk to you of course is
that risk any greater than you driving
to work on a normal day driving 10 miles
to work on a normal day
probably not seriously if you're 30
years old and you're not living in New
York City the chances and you're healthy
the chances that you're gonna die from
Cove in 19 are I would imagine about the
same as being killed in a car accident
like that and that's not me suggesting
that by the way that's John ionizes from
Stanford and that's been his statistical
suggestion that was play by the way his
statistics is even broader he says if
you're under 65 and in good health your
chances are about the same of dying in a
car accident driving over nine miles in
a day as they are of dying from from
kovin 19 so what exactly does reopening
look like amidst all this nobody who's
actually put forward a plan through the
plans that are put forward Morgan
Stanley put forward a plan yesterday
suggesting that people should only go
back to work in the middle of July which
is just not sustainable that's not a
thing that's going to happen especially
when you have lockdowns of this nature I
mean people are human beings they are
living very different lives right now I
have a friend Bethany Mandel and she's
been tweeting consistently about what
it's like for parents who have kids with
some sort of condition right if you have
kids about a TD or kids who have OCD you
have kids who have who have a problem at
home the reversions that kids are
experiencing because they're locked up I
don't mean like these are real life
situations and to pretend that suffering
is binary that either you're dead or
you're alive if there isn't a tremendous
amount of suffering that goes on for
people who lose their livelihoods their
jobs who watch
the kids transformed by being locked
inside that's idiocy - and it's
unsympathetic idiocy as well telling me
get to reopening the states and what
exactly people are talking about in
doing so we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you really want to know who is at
your door these days whether or not you
are home you want to make sure that the
that the Amazon guy didn't just sneeze
on the package and then hand it to you
you also want to make sure that as local
governments let criminals out of prison
because this is what they are doing that
your property is protected and frankly I
have little kids they like to run around
on my property and I want to have keep
an eye on them but I don't want to be
running around outside with them the
entire time I got work to do ring will
allow you to do all of these things ring
gives you protection at every corner
helps you create custom affordable
security for your home ring detects
motion when people come on your property
rings video doorbells let you answer the
door check in on your home anytime from
anywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivery or a surprise
visitor you'll get an alert you'll be
able to see here and speak to them all
from your phone get peace of mind
knowing that your loved ones are safe
the all-new ring video doorbell 3 is
upgraded with additional security
features and works on any home you can
see and speak with visitors with HD
video 2-way talk and phone notifications
when your doorbell detects movement and
you can adjust which areas to get motion
alerts so you only receive alerts you
care about because who cares if the door
is swinging open on your on in the back
of the house if you already know who's
out there we've had ring for years we
feel much more secure because of it you
should feel more secure to get a special
offer on the ring welcome kit when you
go to ring it calm / been that welcome
kit includes the ring video doorbell 3
and chime Pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today go to ring at calm slash pen that
is ring calm / Ben go check them out
right now ok so the big debate that is
broken out is how these how these states
are going to be reopened it is unclear
exactly what is being planned in terms
of reopening the there are a series of
governor's yesterday who announced that
they were going to put together a plan
for reopening governors of Connecticut
Delaware Massachusetts New Jersey New
York and Rhode Rhode Island in
Pennsylvania all suggested that they
were going to create a committee of
public health officials economic
development officials and their chiefs
of staff and on the west coast the
governors of California Oregon and
Washington announced a joint approach to
reopening economies they called it a
Western States pact they said our states
will only be effective by working
together
governor Gavin Newsom of Cal
you said on Tuesday he would outline the
California based thinking on reopening
promised that it would be guided by
facts evidence and science the city of
Los Angeles has already extended stay at
home order through May 15 that is hard
to imagine that it can be extended much
beyond that in Texas governor Greg
Abbott says that he is working closely
with the White House on his plan to
reopen in the state's business and he's
called for a staggered approach in which
businesses that have a minimal impact on
the spread of virus would open up first
okay now all of this broke out into the
open because governors rightly so are
talking about reopening their states
they should be talking about this there
should be a local and state process
number one because local and state
governments should be that they're
closest to the people that are closest
to their their own areas I mean frankly
I think that there's a good case we made
that may or should be making these
decisions of local towns looking at what
is the population in my area how dense
is the population in my area how Bad's
we know the infection is in my area I
mean those are the people who are most
concerned I don't see why somebody 3,000
miles away from me should be making this
decision frankly I don't see why even
Eric Garcetti should be making this
decision for people who live in the
valley I just think that I think the
local rule is the best rule when it
comes to this sort of stuff because
populations are indeed at different
risks people live in different ways the
associations are different I think aside
from a few sort of basic provisos like
don't gather in crowds of 50,000 and try
to socially distance and try to wear
face masks so you're not infecting other
people I think other than that the
national government really doesn't have
a lot to say about any of this
nonetheless president Trump bizarrely
yesterday suggested that he was going to
go to war with governors over their own
policies on this I think he is both in
the belief that he's going to say open
the economy and then governors are going
to say I don't want the economy open and
then he is going to look as though he
doesn't care about human life so he's
worried about the the idea that
governors are going to keep the economy
closed beyond when he wants to keep the
economy closed well it seems to me that
he has a pretty easy counter-argument
which is your governor is basically
keeping you in your home and there's not
a lot of evidence that the state next
door is doing poorly so why don't you
talk to your governor about it it's not
my fault not my fault is a pretty good
position to be in one your presidents of
the United States and by the way it also
happened to be true a while ago right
the media had been trying to blame Trump
for all things coronavirus related the
media I've been trying to suggest that
the Trump administration
Russians response was way out of line
with everybody else on earth and that
that is not really true okay if you take
a look for example at the timelines for
other countries what you see is that the
united states declared a public health
emergency on January 31st President
Trump declared a national emergency on
March 13th he announced his 15 days to
slow the spread coronavirus guidance on
March 16th
it wasn't until March 14th that the
Spanish government declared a two-week
state of emergency and instituted a
lockdown it was only on March 16th but
the friends president McCrone announced
mandatory home confinement for 15 days
and it was that same day during his
daily press briefing that British prime
minister Boris Johnson urged citizens to
work from home and avoid pubs and
restaurants
it wasn't until March 21st that the
French had summoned the French National
Assembly approved a legal text that
would introduce a state of health
emergency also the Trump administration
banned travel from China on January 31st
it'll leads it to the UK and France
didn't do any of that stuff so the idea
that the Trump administration was
notoriously late on all this yeah they
were later than they should have been
they should have been like early March
but they were not significantly later in
major ways than a lot of other European
countries okay with all of that said I'm
bewildered as to why Trump is trying to
claim total authority over these
governors he should be saying listen you
know he screwed up in New York truly who
is closest to this and who screwed up
Bill DeBlasio and Andrew Cuomo so
they're gonna claim I screwed up you got
a look at the people in charge in New
York and also they do have the authority
to declare reopening states have all
sorts of plenary authority in this area
if they want to keep people locked down
that's on them I've recommended that we
reopen they're keeping you locked down
so if you don't like that talk to your
governor and conversely if your governor
reopens and you think that you should be
closed talk to your governor
that is how federalism works and I'm
frankly shocked I don't know why Trump
said this he said I have total authority
I'm gonna go to war with the governors
for what purpose to what end
here's President Trump yesterday's
bizarre if a governor issued a stay at
home when you say my authority the
president's authority that might because
it's not me this is when somebody's the
president of the United States the
authority is total and that's so it's
got to be your 30 schools total
and the governors know that the
governor's Senate but now you have a
couple of bands of excuse me excuse me
you have a couple did you receive that
you have a couple of bands of Democrat
governor's but they will agree to it
they won't reach other but the authority
of the President of the United States
having to do with the subject we're
talking about is total no it is not it
is in fact not total okay this is not
emperor palpatine absolute power no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no we
have a constitution for precisely this
reason we have states for precisely this
reason then bizarrely Trump tweeted out
this morning
tell the Democrat governors that mutiny
on the bounty it was one of my all-time
favorite movies a good old-fashioned
mutiny every now and then is an exciting
and invigorating thing to watch
especially when the mutineers it needs
so much from the captain to easy what
does that even mean like what what now
and also if we're gonna talk mutiny
right now and you're talking like this
it sounds more like Captain queeg from
from the Caine Mutiny then it sounds
like mutiny on the bounty right here
by the way mutiny on the bounty was
about a captain who wanted to lock his
ship down tight and sailors who did not
want to be locked down for a period of
time so it is actually the opposite the
situation is talking about is the is the
assumption of the suite that Trump is
going to leverage Authority in order to
force the states to reopen because I
don't understand how he can do that or
why he would do that frankly and it's
just it's it's political idiocy I do not
understand why any of this would be the
point like what is why just why but
there's so much Y happening right now
like there are so many things that Trump
could be doing right now to unify the
country and this is just not one of them
now that doesn't mean that he is not
fighting a continuing war with the media
we'll get to that in just one second but
first let's talk about the fact is that
you need to have your legal house in
order right now like you run a business
you got to have your legal house in
order and you need to do it without
going away from your house because I
mean frankly you cannot go away from
your house health and safety is on the
top of everybody's minds right now no
matter what happens you want to make
sure that your loved ones are protected
this is one of the reasons why you
should set up a nice will and a state
plan without leaving your home you need
a you need some sort of document here is
it a last
well and Testament or living trust how
about in advanced health care directive
what is power of attorney well you don't
have to call up a lawyer and spend tons
of money on an hourly fee instead head
on over to Legal Zoom I've been using
Legal Zoom for years long before they're
an advertiser on the program legal zooms
online resources make it easy to get
started if you need to speak to an
attorney they're independent attorney
network is there to guide and advise you
Legal Zoom is not a law firm so you
won't have to worry about expensive
billable hours adding up take a really
important step before your families this
does protect your family particularly if
you're talking about like a living trust
or will situation you wanna make sure
the government doesn't just pry open
your safe and take all of your money
after god forbid your plots go to Legal
Zoom calm get started on that last well
living trust or more find out how you
can speak to an attorney for advice on
the right estate plan Legal Zoom is
where life meets legal go check them out
right now and save yourself a bundle of
money not spending hourly fees so
President Trump said that at his at his
briefing and again it's because Trump is
a counter-puncher and because people
have been questioning him incessantly
and so he ends up going off on the press
we'll get to that in just one second
first let me recommend that you head on
over to daily wire and become an insider
plus or all-access remember right now
when you become a daily wire insider
plus our all-access member you get this
not just one leftist here's tumbler 2
left is tears tumblers so if you have
two mouths you can swig from it or if
there's someone else who lives you know
how that probably makes more sense if
you have two people who live in your
house and they each one left the stairs
tumbler now with one membership you get
two of those magical magical leftist
tears tumblers daily where members get a
lot of them incredible benefits they get
of course now two of these you also get
an ad-free website experienced access to
all of our live broadcast and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight op-eds
from moi salem where members also get to
ask us questions during backstage and he
gets participate in all access live
which is super popular we didn't all
access live it last night from my guest
house the way that this works is that I
wear a t-shirt and then I just chat with
you I know the t-shirt is really the
pitch this is content for our all-access
members but for now everybody who's a
member gets access so go download the
daily wire wrapping at all of our great
content on the go when you become any
sort of member again become an insider
plus or all-access member double the
leftist years with two leftist years
tumblers go to daily wire calm slash
subscribe to get started and get 10% off
with coupon code Shapiro
that is daily wire calm / subscribe
coupon code Shapiro got the rarest of
all beverage vessels times - it is
indeed
magical magical so so magical you're
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in America
[Music]
you
so you know that President Trump is
trying to figure out exactly how to
reopen everyone is trying to figure out
exactly how to reopen and there is no
great answer because there are certain
businesses that are just gonna be hard
hit we know that that big theme parks
and using parks like Disneyland it's
gonna be a while before any of that
reopens even in in Shanghai Disney
Resort in China guess at Shanghai Resort
have to wear masks at all times they can
only remove them for eating hours and
capacity are limited to gain entry
visitors have to submit to a temperature
check and present the
government-controlled QR phone QR code
on their phone that indicates their
virus-free
okay thatthat stuff ain't happening in
the United States this is not gonna
happen says Neal and just won't reopen
until there is a vaccine presumably or
until the levels of of death from kovat
19 reach incredible lows hopefully over
the summer and then we hope that there
is no second wave here with all of that
said airlines are gonna be hard hit
travel is gonna be hard hit Hotel is
gonna be hard hit small businesses are
just gonna get crushed and one of the
things that people should be talking
about is how to continue to support
small businesses in the absence of any
sort of market because right now there
is no market and so there's a good case
to be made that small businesses should
be continued to be floated grants from
the federal government in order to in
order to maintain their employees on a
non-profit going forward basis and then
if they want to start earning profit
again then they can stop taking those
grants business leaders and the CDC are
warning that the economic recovery is
going to be slow according to the New
York Times the evidence suggests it's
not just stay-at-home orders and other
government restrictions that have
chilled economic activity it's a
behavioral response from workers and
consumers scared of contracting the
virus that of course is true one of the
things that is happening here and this
is one of the reasons why I think people
what we need to figure out how to get
out of this as soon as possible is there
is a sort of mentality setting and I can
feel it myself so I assume that I'm
filling in others which is you feel that
the safer at home orders make you feel
safer at home and so you start to get
into this rut which is like is it really
truly that scary to go out to the mall
right now like if I went out to the mall
with a mask and I socially distance what
I feel truly frightened and the answer
is that when you are in the news all day
long kind of right kinda you go to the
grocery store and you feel freaked out
okay the chances that you're gonna
acquire this thing at a grocery store
wearing a mask and socially distancing
are basically nil but everyone
is freaked out all of the time and the
longer this goes on the more freaked out
people are gonna be and the longer it's
gonna be before people engage in
precisely this sort of economic activity
that supports small businesses and so it
actually is imperative not just for you
know plain business reasons but for
psychological reasons for people to go
out and really engage with the world
which is why again I'm suggesting that
quick-and-dirty
might in fact be much more practical and
practicable than anything that anybody
else is talking about right now okay
with all of that said as I say Trump got
in a fight with governor's yesterday and
then he got in a fight with the press
yesterday now let me start with this
premise the press have been awful on
this they've been awful from day one
they've been focused laser-like on the
suggestion the president from blue.this
they've been suggesting that since the
first day and they've been focusing
incessantly on failures during late
January and February and as I've said
before when the book is written about
how all of this went down there will be
failures in late January in February
early from the CDC and the FDA and
testing law authorities they're gonna be
failures inside the Trump administration
Trump should have taken it seriously
maybe two three weeks earlier minimum
okay all of that is going to be written
but the other thing that's gonna be
written is that there was a series of
failures for 20 years leading up to this
thing there were failures at the state
and local level because that's what
always happens in the lead-up to a
government disaster yes there was a memo
in the lead-up to 9/11 that said al
Qaeda determined to attack in United
States it was vague it was not clear
what exactly the United States should do
about that it said they were gonna use
airplanes but it didn't say what they're
gonna do with the airplanes yes that was
a screw-up by the Bush administration
you know what else was a screw-up
letting bin Laden live for 15 years
before that under the Clinton
administration so everybody's been
focused in on Trump and one of the
things that really is most despicable
that I think some members of the media
are trying to do is divide off dr.
Anthony Fauci from Trump now listen I
don't think that Trump should simply be
listening to everything found she says
and then green-lighting it I think that
he's the President of the United States
he ought to have a variety of voices in
his ear to come up with a good policy
does mean balancing not just the
epidemiological approach but also the
economic approach and also the public
health approach beyond Epidemiology I
mean the fact is that nobody has taken
into account the mental effects on the
American people of 30 million people
losing their jobs and people being
forced to stay in their homes nobody has
taken into account the public health
effects of people staying home for
elective surgeries what we're watching
right now is hospitals actually go
out of business in the middle of a
corona virus pandemic because the only
thing they're all being allowed to care
for is corona virus they're not allowed
to go out and do all of the surgeries
they actually pay the doctors and pay
the nurses and keep the hospitals open
so we're gonna have to have them go back
to doing those sorts of things obviously
okay
well president Trump is in the middle of
this thing is being questioned about
Falchi because the media are trying to
divide him off from foul cheese I don't
know what the purpose is maybe so they
can claim that Trump is not listening to
the experts or something and it really
is Grosso Trump the other day made a big
boo-boo right he he retweeted a bizarre
tweet suggesting mini fire Falchi now
the rest of the tweet was about how foul
she had been saying in late February
everything was gonna be okay which
happens to be true and Trump probably
retweeted it without reading the end of
the tweet right the actual answer here
is that Trump doesn't read entire tweets
his retweeted criticism of him before
without knowing it because he reads the
first seven words of a tweet and then
just hits retweet but Trump was asked
about why he retweeted this thing about
fire Falchi the media drooling hoping to
open a rift between the two of them
today I walk in I hear I'm gonna fire
him I'm not firing I think he's a
wonderful fired somebody know they said
far doesn't matter did you notice that
when they read everything I was thought
about that I said I'm not firing
effective you ask your friends in the
office and the public relations office I
was immediately called upon that and I
said no I like him I think he's doing
thing as if ouchy was asked about this
and found she's just so irritated by
this point like Trump actually enjoys
the back-and-forth with the media my
Trump lives for this Trump loves being
the center of attention the dirty little
secret the media love the media Trump
loves Trump and so they love it
Trump loves it when people talk about
him and the media love it when somebody
talks about them so the only people
enjoying this whole Trump versus the
media thing our Trump and the media
those are the people enjoying this
everybody else out here was like so am I
gonna die or not and we're all like what
are you talking like air about this foul
she was one of those people right foul
she was asked about this and he's like
I'm not being fired stop with this
garbage this is so stupid
you can see how irritated found she is
here somebody didn't like the way I
answered it so they hashtag that fire
foul shame that's that's it that's the
world we live and I accept it it doesn't
bother me but can the president fire you
well it depends on what you mean by fire
me I'm on the task for as serving at his
pleasure he could be moved me for the
task force I was with him for quite a
while today he has no intention of doing
that okay and then foul she was asked
about whether Trump acted quickly
because remember he was on Jake Tapper
and tapper had said would we have saved
more lives if we did something in
February and found she was like well I
mean sure but if we had acted last
August we would have saved morale here
air is foul Chee clarifying himself the
first and only time that dr. Burks and I
went in and formally made a
recommendation to the president to
actually have a quote shut down in the
sense of not really shut down but to
really have strong mitigation we
discussed it obviously they would be
concerned by some that in fact that
might have some negative consequences
nonetheless the president listened to
the recommendation and went to the
mitigation okay and then fatuous asked
if he was being put up there as a puppet
by Paula Reid from CBS News and CBS was
touting this is like what great
questioning and found using are you
serious right now like you think that
I'm just Trump's meat puppet is that
your is that your actual suggestions has
been working in government for decades
it's just absurd
here's pouchy again being tried the
media trying to manipulate it so that
it's out you will say something bad
about Trump's that trumple get mad and
fire him that was the wrong choice of
words you know what it was when people
discuss not necessarily in front of the
president when people discuss they say
well you know this is gonna have maybe a
harmful effect on this or on that so
what was the poor choice of words it
wasn't anybody saying no you shouldn't
do that everything I do is voluntarily
please don't even imply that okay and
good for a good for pouchy so the media
was doing this routine yesterday and so
president from at the presser decided to
go directly back after the media now
full credit to Chris Cuomo so Chris
Cuomo did a radio show yesterday in
which he was asked specifically about
his job at CNN
basically said since I've had
coronavirus I'm realizing my job is
really stupid yeah
honestly like slow clap for Chris Cuomo
correct correct if your entire job
consists of just sitting there and
bitching about Trump although then yes
that's a stupid job here's Chris Cuomo
basically admitting as much I don't want
to spend my time doing things that I
don't think that are valuable enough to
me personally like what well I don't
like what I do professionally I've
decided I like doing this show I like
talking to you guys but I don't value
indulging irrationality
hyper-partisanship I don't think it's
worth my time okay so again he is he is
correct about this but the media love it
right so it took a life-and-death
experience for Cuomo to recognize that
the media are really all about this
stuff and they really are right Trump
loves it because Trump loves him Trump
and the media because the media love
them some media so yesterday President
Trump went after the media he said
listen here's the timeline of me doing
things right here was Trump ripping into
the media how do you close down the
greatest economy in the history of the
world when on January 17th
you have no cases and no death when on
January 21st you have one case and no
death one case think of that now we're
supposed to close down the country but
here's what happened when on January
31st I instituted the ban
Joe Biden went crazy he said you don't
need the band you he didn't go crazy
like he just he didn't even know what
the hell the ban was okay and he is not
wrong about this and then Trump went on
he actually showed a long video of
members of the media talking about him
and and ripping him for the for the
China flight ban he's like a
three-minute video talking about how he
was right and everybody else was wrong
and so the media lose it yesterday like
they completely lose it so just to show
you the media bias so here's the
difference between CNN's Chiron's and
the other chi runs okay so CNN's chi
runs yesterday
we're just absurd right New York Times
experts aide tried to warn Trump of
Corona vie
threat ok Fox News says Trump defends
reaction to virus outbreak Fox News's
Chiron is more accurate okay that is a
more accurate Chiron okay and then there
were more chi runs are the the CNN
basically says Trump use is the CNN was
Trump uses task force briefing to try
and rewrite history on coronavirus
response that's an editorial and then
Fox News says Trump want to correct fake
news that's an accurate headline so the
media we're treating this is like CNN
did a great job with its kind on CNN did
a crap job with it sky runs you on why
Trump is dumping all over the media cuz
you are Trump Trump is you you guys are
just the Marx Brothers without the
mirror there right and you're just doing
the the hand motion silently and it's
Groucho on one end and Harpole on the
other and eventually you just step
through the mirror and you're still
mirroring each other right that's what
you guys are right CNN had a Chiron said
angry Trump turns briefing into
propaganda session fast news said Trump
once to keep media honest okay again CNN
was just like all in on this thing and
it was ridiculous ridiculous okay so CNN
John King then he gets up said that was
propaganda it was just pure propaganda
what do you think press briefings are
have you ever been to a press briefing
they're giving the administration side
of the story and is it not similarly
propaganda when the members of the media
sit there and ask questions they would
only ask to Republicans in the same way
ninety seven times here is John King
going after Trump for being mean to me
oh poor media oh I feel so bad for you
ohohoh
again ask as many tough questions as you
want of Trump but I think Trump is
handling this in the smartest possible
way no I think he should be saying right
now listen you guys are focused on all
the wrong things you know the American
people care about how we stop people
from dying you know they don't care
about your petty little attempts to get
on television right that's it I think
Trump would be well within his rights to
say that but to pretend that the media
and Trump are not two sides of the same
coin is absurdity here is John King on
hey he was propagated that the righteous
indignation in Pearl clutching is just
ridiculous that was propaganda that was
not just a campaign video that was
propaganda aired at taxpayer expense in
the White House briefing room and it was
selectively cherry-picking information
again the president has every right to
be proud of imposing the travel
restrictions on China yes every right to
defend himself is every right to push
back he has every right to challenge
things that are factually not true but
to play a propaganda
at taxpayer expense in the White House
briefing room is a new you can insert
your favorite word here in this
administration there are ways to do
things even even when he's strung
together clips that back his case and
you don't like it wow I get that sounds
kind of like CNN except like they do it
to attack Trump okay and then you have
Jim Acosta saying this is the biggest
meltdown of I've ever seen really like
cuz I've seen Jim Acosta on TV a lot
here's Jim Acosta and ladies find you a
man who loves you like Jim Acosta loves
Jim Acosta here's Jim Acosta saying it's
the biggest meltdown I've ever seen and
I've seen tons of meltdowns cuz I'm Jim
Acosta and let me tell you every morning
in the mirror when I look in the mirror
and I see Jim Acosta they tell you
there's a handsome man that Jim Acosta
here's Jim Acosta talking about Jim
Acosta having viewed meltdowns as Jim
Acosta while watching a press conference
being Jim Acosta that is the biggest
meltdown I have ever seen from a
president of the United States in my
career I don't think a reasonable person
could watch what we just saw over the
last hour and conclude that the
president is in control he sounds like
he is out of control and he was ranting
and raving for the better part of the
last hour during that news conference as
John King was just saying he's claiming
that he has authorities that he doesn't
have the Constitution does not give the
president United States total Authority
and I thought it was very illuminating
that Vice President Mike Pence got up
there at the podium and and described
the president's authority as plenary or
absolute that is not the case that is a
fact check false okay again the fact
that you've got some media who are so
angry at this they're saying here's the
truth media love it they love every
single solitary second of this every
single moment because any time they get
to talk about the battle between Trump
in the media then they were happy to do
it
you want to write Trump's approval
ratings are low and why the media
approval ratings are low because they
are mirror images of one another the
American people don't give two craps
about any of this I don't care about it
I don't care about Trump attacking
Acosta I don't care about Trump
attacking CBS news reporters I don't
care about them trying to trying to play
gotcha with Anthony Fauci I think it's a
complete waste of time nobody will ask
simple solid straightforward questions
like honest honestly
questions like how gonna make you say
that we need to have contact tracing
what is the practical plan to have
contact tracing be available you say
that we are going to need
millions of tests what is the practical
plan to make that available and what is
the timeline for the availability you
said we needed an ICU bed increases and
ventilator increases to the point where
the curve would not exceed the line when
do we know that that has been like these
are very simple questions why have you
not done random testing across the
United States in terms of antibodies or
in terms of just forget about
asymptomatic cases just cases generally
why have you not done general testing so
that we have some idea of what the base
rate is here
these are simple easy questions that
I've been asking every day on this show
and no one in the media goes to the
press briefing and asks and ask those
questions instead it's all why you so
mean to everybody mr. Trump why are you
so mean mr. president you're being mean
again who gives a flying crap I don't
care do you care we're talking about the
possibility of mass death here and
they're all like oh well he was mean and
he was propagandizing talk about beltway
inside a garbage is the definition of it
alright we'll do a quick thing I like
and then we'll get to a thing that I
hate so things that I like today so as
I've mentioned I'm spending an awful lot
of time indoors with my children and
that means reading them books so there
is a book recommended I believe it might
have been by Tim Carney on Twitter
called the blue book of stories by Tom
long Ghana and it is just highly amusing
the whole thing is a series of stories
kind of in in Lewis a course style about
fifth grade boys and they're very and
being 5th grade boys they're very funny
they're very clever and and they're
really enjoyable it's also pretty well
written so go check that out if you if
you've got a 5th grade boy or kids who
are younger like my daughter's in
kindergarten and she loved it she
thought it was hilarious the blue book
of stories by Tom wangan oh and spend
some time reading dear kids it really is
a pleasure it's it's really one of the
more joyous experience of my life at
this point already time for a thing that
I hate
already so this shall be many things
that I hate many things that I hate so
hilariously the last few days have seen
a bunch of endorsements for Joe Biden
all it took was for everyone else to
endorse Joe Biden for Barack Obama to
endorse Joe Biden so this morning Barack
Obama came out and endorsed Joe Biden he
said I'm proud to endorse my friend Joe
Biden for President of the United States
let's go well here we are I guess
everybody else is out of the race I
guess a year since you declared and um I
didn't endorse me I'm basically useless
I led from behind did nothing for a year
I am a good friend I'm the best friend
I'm the guy you call when every other
person will not drive you to the airport
and all the cabs are broken and then
maybe I was rival to the airport and
maybe not maybe I'll do it after the
planes left that's what I don't I'm the
president Barack Obama let me jump
that's what this is so I love the fact
that Barack Obama's endorsement is
actually less impactful than Bernie
Sanders endorsement at this point
because he waited so long like imagine
if Barack Obama had endorsed Joe Biden
before South Carolina then he'd be
getting all the credit but Obama never
had any coattails not for any other
Democrat and his Democratic Party got
wiped out while he was president wiped
out in Congress wiped out in the Senate
wiped out on the gubernatorial level
wiped out in the state legislatures and
this is one of the reasons why because
for all the talk about how Donald Trump
is an egotist which he assuredly is
Barack Obama is a massive egotist as
well and he was not willing to jump on
the Joe Biden bandwagon specifically
because he was concerned that Joe was
old and see now which by the way Joe
Biden is is old and Cena you may have no
you may have noticed that so that was
the second most important endorsement of
the last 24 hours
the first most important endorsement
with Bernie Sanders I have to admit I do
love the fact that Bernie Sanders just
cut off
Alexander Ocasio cortes at the knees it
is beautiful so yesterday morning there
was a piece by asket Herndon over at the
New York Times called Alexander Oh Cosmo
Cortes has never spoken to Joe Biden
here's what she would say in an
interview mr. Cozzi Oh Cortes said she
intended to support the presumptive
Democratic nominee but the process of
coming together should be uncomfortable
for everyone involved she wanted to make
demands demands of Joe Biden so that the
entire progressive wing would get behind
the Joe Biden campaign she said that the
Biden campaign had not reached out to
her she said there's this talk about
unity as this kind of vague kumbaya kind
of term unity and unifying isn't a
feeling it's a process
and what I hope does not happen is that
everyone just tries to shoo it along and
brush reel policies that means the
difference of life and death are
affording your insulin and not affording
your insulin just press that brush them
under the rug as an aesthetic difference
of style there's also this idea that we
all just support the nominee voters will
come along as well I don't think this
conversation about changes that need to
be made is one about throwing the
progressive wing of the party a couple
of bones I think this is how we can win
so she says that she wants the Medicare
age lowered to 60 and they floated this
out I love this they floated this olive
branch to the progressive left she says
of lowering the Medicare age to 60 it's
almost insulting I think Hillary was
looking at policies that lowered it to
50 so we're talking about a progressive
concession that is 10 you're worse than
the nominee we had back in 2016
progressives aren't like a monolith like
every voting bloc is in a monolith but I
know from a Latino perspective I think
we need a real plan to be better than
what happened during his service with
the Obama administration I love she says
that that progressives onto monolith but
there is a monolithic Latino perspective
very interesting and then she says that
she wants some sort of concessions on
deportations she says if we're not
talking about path to citizenship for
undocumented people if we're just
talking about policy changes and five or
ten percent it's not about moving to the
left
it's about who is able to find hope in
your administration so she has this long
interview with The New York Times
talking about all the things that she
wants from Joe Biden in order for her to
endorse and 5 seconds later Bernie
Sanders gets on a live stream with Joe
Biden and endorses now the great shock
here is that both of them were able to
work the live stream and that is clearly
the great shock here there must've been
a grandkid nearby who was able to to
work the camera but watching watching
Stadler and Hofstetter from the Muppets
talk to each other here was really an
experience or Sam the Eagle and Larry
David that was it was really an
experience that's kind of what they what
they look like here have you ever seen a
show this bad no I've not seen a show
this bad since I walked out on the
Ford's Theater in 19 1865 so Bernie
Sanders finally endorses joe biden for
president bernie is joe biden's doing it
from his well-lit basement and his
forehead continues to climb up his
entire head it now constitutes the
entire front portion of
of his cranium like his forehead
actually starts midway through the top
of his skull and now descends all the
way to his nose Joe Biden's forehead and
then he got Bernie Sanders who's like I
know I'm irrelevant no but I have one
more shot to say I think and Here I am
the best part of this is that it was a
live stream where they were supposed to
be casual and fun and Bert and Joe Biden
was desperately trying to read off a
teleprompter during the entire thing
because Joe Biden has lost all capacity
for independent human thought it's over
for him he has no Quebec like he just
he's a he's a Joe Biden bot but like a
crappy bought version point-seven not
the one that was supposed to be released
he's a o L 1.0 with the dial-up
connection so so here's Bernie endorsing
Biden with sufficiently more enthusiasm
than Joe Biden who is not actually in a
live person we've got to make Trump a
one-term president and we need you in in
the White House so I will do all that I
can to see that that happens Joe and I
know that there is an enormous
responsibility on your shoulders right
now and it's imperative that all of us
work together to do what has to be done
not only in this moment but beyond this
moment in the future of this country
okay and then Biden did a bunch of
stupid things so Biden thinks that the
way that he is going to unify the party
is by making all sorts of concessions to
Bernie and by starting to mimic Bernie's
policies and this is pretty much the
dumbest thing you can do the reason that
this is the dumbest thing you can do is
his Biden's entire campaign the reason
he shall act Bernie and he shall act
burning way worse than Hillary chillax
Bernie in 2016 right Hillary narrowly
beat Bernie Biden just killed him
I mean Biden whomped him he won 11 out
of 14 Super Tuesday states the moment
that people saw Bernie as a possible
frontrunner Bernie collapsed in on
himself like the Soviet economy circa
1987 okay and so why would you at this
point attempt desperately to mimic
Bernie Sanders's policies you just
killed him you just say he's dead
already what are you doing what are you
doing like the best move here that Joe
Biden could have made was to completely
joffrey Bernie Sanders right Bernie
Bernie bends the knee and Biden just
lopped off his head and selects Amy
Klobuchar as his VP or something okay
but he didn't do that instead Biden had
to pay homage
Berni he says that bernie is one of the
most powerful voices ever of course he's
reading from a teleprompter while he
says this means a great deal to me
personally as I said in my statement
when you suspend at your campaign I want
to thank you for being the powerful
voice and you've been the most powerful
voice for a fair and more just America
it's a voice like yours that refuses to
allow us just to accept what is you've
refused to accept that we can't change
what's wrong in our nation you refuse to
accept that health and well-being of our
fellow citizens and our planet isn't the
responsibility of somebody else that's
our responsibility Act night and you
don't get enough credit Bernie you don't
you don't get enough credit because I've
been denying you credit because I think
you're a crazy old loon bag I have a
crazy old blue bag of course I'm a crazy
old loon bag and you're going to give me
all the things that I don't need to do
that I killed you know you're going to
do and some fightin is like oh okay fine
so then he starts saying crazy crap
which again is not going to benefit him
in the election so here's Joe Biden
saying crazy crap right he says you know
what I think we should do was use
wartime authority to force banks to give
small loans to businesses wartime
authority to force banks to give loans
they would not otherwise give so we're
not just gonna use the government to
give out bad loans like we did during
the subprime crisis or like we did
during tarp or something we are actually
going to four small banks to give loans
they don't want to give using wartime
Authority which is just full on economic
fascism I mean that is what that is when
you seize control of the banks and force
them to give loans that is basically the
definition of economic fascism here is
here is Joe Biden
suggesting it openly because he doesn't
know what he's talking about he's lost
all connection with reality we should
insist that the Trump White House and
the Treasury Department move more
aggressively to get those grants and
loans to small businesses now when they
really need it and if the banks won't do
it to go back to your point the
processing they won't process the loans
for small business regardless of their
size then the federal government should
use their wartime authority to compel
them to do so because otherwise in six
months we're gonna look back and see
this crisis has only made inequity worse
in America so we're gonna use the
government for redistribution of wealth
in the middle of a global pandemic and
he says this again right he says let's
do a green new deal let's
let's pursue progressive priorities let
me be clear about something one of the
reasons you are not seeing like outright
state refusal to listen to the federal
government is the fact that Donald Trump
is president if these people the people
who are insisting on full-scale federal
control to every aspect of your life
were using this crisis as an excuse to
take control of businesses and banks
across the country there would be
rightly talk of disobeying the federal
government there would be like one of
the things that is keeping things on
lockdown right now is the fact that
Trump obviously does not want to
fundamentally shift the nature of the
relationship between citizen and
government Joe Biden is scaring this is
scary okay because this is Joe Biden
being burnt being Bernie and this just
shows that for the Democratic Party
their heart is still with Bernie even
though they're not willing to show it on
the outside so here is Joe Biden being
Bernie on on progressive policies while
Bernie sits there bored and staring at
his fingernails look the United States
has no choice but to seize this
opportunity and create millions millions
of great paying jobs that your energy
plan is suggested and mine as well an
energy infrastructure of tomorrow not
going back to anything I was before
tomorrow and we take a backseat to no
one when it comes to fighting climate
change or when it comes to creating
good-paying jobs middle class jobs union
jobs union jobs what are you talking
about we have 30 million people who are
out of work here we've gained 17 million
people on the unemployment rolls you
want to lose an election this is the way
to lose an election seriously is to say
crazy radical things that Trump can
actually pick on in the run-up to the
election the other way to lose the
election is to be a complete buffoon and
that Biden has done in spades
he made three separate gas in this thing
last night first he names the economy
twice in his working groups which is
like the full-on Rick Perry but he
doesn't get treated like Rick Perry
because he's Joe Biden we just pretend
he's old senile uncle Joe here he is
gaffe number one Bernie and I have
agreed to establish as we said we were
already talked about it six policy
working groups one on the economy one on
education one on criminal justice it
should be reform not punishment one on
immigration climate change and the
economy Oh like the economy twice well
that's that's important also gaffe
number two then he's trying to get his
aides attention member that time the
Marco Rubio swig from a water bottle and
it was a huge deal
here is Joe Biden trying desperately to
get his aides attention in the middle of
a live stream with so many folks on
employee and underemployed we've got to
make sure that the government comes up
with a continued set of policies that
protect those workers and the pain all
over the country is now horrific you
I've seen as I have these lines of cause
and I mean what is Joe Biden doing here
he's like trying to spoon something is
it like what's good what's going on
this is this is song and dance at the
old-age home finally gaffe number three
Biden says he's gonna put millions of
citizens on the pathway to citizenship
which would be weird because citizens
don't need a pathway to citizenship as
the word citizenship would actually
suggest I really think we should be
thinking about having a new office a new
cabinet office on pandemics in the
United States but that's another issue
but we're gonna finally achieve
comprehensive immigration reform as well
put millions of citizens on a pathway to
citizenship including so many who are in
the front lines right now the the number
of undocumented who are out there now
risking their lives what is he talking
about okay so this crazy old kook I'm so
glad that everyone is proud to endorse
including Barack Obama who literally was
left with only one option so good stuff
there Democrats listen Biden is a super
vulnerable candidate he maintains that
vulnerability but Trump is gonna have to
actually demonstrate some leadership
he's gonna have to forego the cheap and
easy hit against the media and actually
demonstrate some desire to unify the
country because basically this election
right now is gonna be a referendum on
what Trump does with it with the worst
crisis in modern American history really
since the Civil War okay we'll be back
here later do two additional hours of
content I will not be back here tomorrow
there are two more days of Jewish
holidays
Wednesday and Thursday I will be back
here Friday I promise that's like the
last of the Jewish holidays for
approximately seven weeks until we hit
Shavuot but otherwise show up here later
today and we'll spend a couple more
hours with you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]